GUNTHER ROLAND: There's
a couple of new elements
that we've introduced
in the last few years.
One is that the students write
a proposal for an experiment
that they want to do
and develop themselves.
And for that experiment,
they can use any material
that you have in the lab
or anything that they
can find at MIT and other in
labs of former UROP advisors
or people that they know.
And sometimes even buy
some equipment for them
if it's a particularly
interesting proposal
and we think that it can be
used in future experiments.
So that proposal, develop
your own experiment
and really see through
the whole process
not starting from a
prefabricated experiment
but coming up with
your own, that's
a really unique
experience in 8.14
and I think something
that is very difficult
to find outside of the lab.
And then we also have
included in the last two years
a post-session at the end
that the students present
the results of
their own experiment
to the other students in
the lab, to the staff,
and then to any member of
the physics department that
happens to walk past.
We try to time that with
the physics faculty lounge
so that the big professors
walk past the post-session
and then the students
can explain to them
their own experiment,
what they found
in that part of the course.
So I think that's really
a different than what
you do in 8.13 when you
start with experiments that
have been done by generations
and generations of students
before.
And I think the students
really like that.